un cortège de près de cinq cent mille
personnes dans les rues de paris pour la
gay pride qui porte désormais le nom de
marche des fiertés le monde du travail
il participait cette année des policiers
des pros fond des filets scandale à la
spa l'assemblée générale qui se tient
aujourd'hui demandent que l'on est pur
les comptes le président et l'ancienne
directrice sera entendu prochainement
par la justice
le conseil national du parti socialiste
après la crise l'apaisement ce soir la
direction est élargie autour de françois
hollande laurent fabius devient numéro 2
du ps ni peut-être qu'ils soient porte
parole du parti avait provoqué un
véritable tollé fans la crise laurent
fabius est l'invité de notre journal
plus de 60 ans au service du théâtre et
du cinéma françois périer un acteur
irremplaçable une centaine de films et
80 pièces à son actif
françois périer c'était un l'âge de 82
ans voilà monsieur bonsoir plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes dans
les rues de paris pour la gay pride de
rebaptiser cette année la marche des
fiertés un thème central celui de
l'égalité avec dans le cortège pour la
première fois des policiers des profs
des agents de l'edf bref ceux qui
affichent peu ou pas l'heure où succès
leur homosexualité sur leur lieu de
travail
une évolution de la société qui s'élève
désormais contre toute forme de
discrimination
il y a plusieurs façons de le dire la
revendication ou la fête
yasmina farber année secondaire
une vague arc-en-ciel déferle sur paris
plus de trois cent mille personnes pour
cette marche des fiertés lesbiennes gay
bi et trans
un autre monde pour lequel les
personnels gay d'air france vous invite
à embarquer ils viennent de créer leur
association avec le sens de l'humour et
de l'autodérision
il met aussi incombe ya un nouveau
pratiquer la danse ici pas mais on en
n'est pas vraiment conscient mais tous
les jours la vie au quotidien dans les
avions
nouveauté de cette année
les salariés font leur coming out dans
leur milieu professionnel la sncf à son
char la police sa voiture équipée d'un
gyrophare vrais policiers mais fusil
factice c'est l'association flag
quant aux profs ils font aussi entendre
leur voix pour la première fois dans les
cours de récréation sont encore traités
tous
nous en tant qu'éducateur savez quoi
sert-elle dont il nous semble important
de dire on doit parler d'euro sexualité
à l'école
en tête de cortège le maire de paris
symbole d'une gauche qui a fait avancer
la cause homosexuelle avec le par
l'actuelle majorité n'a qu'un
représentant la droite stigmatise et les
léguer pendant les débats sur le pacs il
faut aujourd'hui que ce soit un très
mauvais souvenir chirac a pris des
engagements
d'ailleurs notamment pénalisé les propos
homophobes limites en attente de
nouveaux droits notamment pour
l'adoption ou pour la reconnaissance du
rôle de leur conjoint dans la cellule
familiale
mais au delà des inquiétudes cette
marche c'est d'abord une grande parade
une fête un spectacle que l'on vient
observer avec curiosité un peu surpris
mais sans ironie
les bonhommes
j'aimais chacun son idée
la fierté gay pink tv voudrait la
diffuser toute l'année sur le câble
nouvelle chaîne prévoit de proposer des
programmes fin 2002 les programmes
culturels et ce textile 24 heures sur 24
cette journée de samedi classée rouge
par bison futé mais pas d'énormes
bouchons comme par le passé
pas même dans la région rhône alpes sur
la route du soleil où le trafic était
dense mais sans plus
signe des temps l'étalement des vacances
des 35 heures et une meilleure écoute
des conseils de la sécurité routière
didier guyot philippe lévêque
c'est dur de partir avec tout le monde à
être les enfants un peu en wec away tous
les gens difficile d'échapper à la foule
aujourd'hui quelques 140 mille voitures
avaient décidé d'emprunter la vallée du
rhône circulation en accordéon attente
au péage bouchons le prix à payer avant
d'atteindre la plage on n'a pas le choix
tout le monde est en vacances et enfants
jouaient ensemble
tout le monde est
et contraint de partir avec les mêmes
dates de location je pense au dessus de
villefranche-sur-saône gendarmes et un
hélicoptère sont sur le qui-vive égard
aux vacanciers qui seraient trop pressé
fatigue stress de la route et chaleur de
la salle tu les moments de détente sont
incontournables pour marie conduisait
puis commence à vraiment envie de dormir
et prendre le volant
un samedi de départ très chargé pour
tous on est loin de longues heures
d'attentes des points noirs que l'on
connaissait avant à la même époque
désormais le flux est presque incessants
duquel je commence on va dire maintenant
le quasiment le jeudi en plein été et se
termine jusque jusqu'au lundi et durant
toute cette période dont un trafic très
soutenu quelques week-ends saturé seront
tout de même à éviter comme le 14
juillet et du 3 août prochain
quand même
du côté du ciel la grève des agents de
sécurité se poursuit provoque comme hier
soir des perturbations à orly-sud toute
la journée des retards d'environ une
heure sur tous les vols vers toutes
destinations
il s'agit d'une grève du zèle de ses
agents qui contrôle les passagers et les
bagages
il manque de moyens personnels distille
depuis le 11 septembre et réclame une
revalorisation de leurs salaires dus à
leur surcroît de travail le mouvement se
poursuivra demain et pourrait même
s'étendre à roissy dès mardi
cette journée de départs en vacances
nous donne l'occasion de nous intéresser
à ces enfants non-accompagnés on les
appelle les humains ils portent leur
fiche signalétique autour du cou et
peuvent à partir de 4 ou 5 ans voyagent
seuls en avion mais selon un dispositif
et une prise en charge de la compagnie
et le narguer et abdel oliech entre
paris et marseille ce matin sipa roues
semaine
et tu vas comment l'avion dans quelques
minutes
direction marseille pour marc dos cinq
ans censé part au niveau où les 10
heures à orly
dix-huit enfants non accompagnés
s'apprête à embarquer point commun la
pochette autour du cou pour les
identifier et des parents plutôt serein
voilà enfin débarrasse phone 7 comme ils
le vivent très bien et où je vois pas
pourquoi nous angoisser ssid
comment vous sentez un petit peu car
c'est désormais le personnel de bord et
responsable du groupe
ces mineurs sont des passagers
prioritaires les premiers à embarquer il
bénéficie d'un régime de faveur
le plafond mou que tu veux tu es trop
figée rem est associé tout honneur à
gogo
à bord la plupart des enfants ont
l'habitude de voyager seules pourquoi
les tunnels nombreux en période de
vacances les mineurs non accompagnés en
souvent des parents divorcés dans cette
compagnie près d'un quart des enfants
transportés voyagent seuls quelques
poissons les vins tranquilles voyage
qu'il quitte à papa pour retrouver les
mamans vont faire donc
et puis ils sont très jeunes ils ont
besoin d'être maternés il faut aller les
voir
en fait ils ont besoin d'une maman un
petit peu après vérification de leur
identité
les familles pourront retrouver leurs
jeunes passagers dans la plupart des
compagnies aériennes ces enfants ne fait
aucun supplément
c'est aussi une manière de fidéliser
très tôt cette clientèle nouvelle
attaque d'une bijouterie cette fois ci
dans le centre de toulouse
plusieurs malfaiteurs ont vidé le coffre
est la vitrine à l'heure de l'ouverture
pour se protéger dans leur fuite ils ont
ligoté bâillonné deux employés puis les
ont aspergés de gaz lacrymogène ces deux
personnes ont été hospitalisées mais pas
d'inquiétude sur leur état de santé
reste que les agresseurs ont réussi à
s'enfuir avec leur butin
autre procédé pour un résultat identique
une attaque à la voiture bélier à
grenoble dans une banque située au coeur
de la ville plusieurs hommes cagoulés
ont réussi à prendre la fuite leur butin
en poche dorothée cochard c'est tout ce
qui reste du braquage une renault espace
calcinés une renault espace que les
braqueurs ont incendié eux-mêmes la
scène a eu lieu hier à l'heure du
déjeuner en plein centre de grenoble
une voiture se précipitent contre la
façade de la banque et quatre hommes en
sortent ainsi ajouter quelque chose en
la voiture la voiture a pris feu
c'est vraiment impressionnant et après
ils sont rentrés ça a duré un bon moment
à l'intérieur je vous les voyez pour
sortir c'est pas ça bien durer deux
trois minutes à l'intérieur ils sont
sortis il est là il y avait des laisses
pas qui les attendait en fallait bouger
mon
ton modeler et il devait y en avoir un
dehors et 3 l'intérieur enfin je pense
du 24 les malfaiteurs étaient cagoulés
et armés cas plus minutes leur ont suffi
pour s'emparer de la caisse
on n'en connaît pas encore la famille
des parfums de scandale à la spa
l'assemblée générale qui se tient
aujourd'hui devrait demander une
épuration des comptes
la cour des comptes avait déjà
stigmatisé l'opacité de la société
protectrice des animaux son nouveau
président comme l'ancienne directrice
sera entendu par la justice la semaine
prochaine les bénévoles n'ont plus le
moral quand aux animaux leur sort n'est
pas toujours enviable mathias hillion
françois-xavier but interdiction de
filmer
l'animosité est pour le moins
perceptible à la spa
l'association est en crise et certains
de ses adhérents sont venus demander des
comptes cet après-midi en grande
discussion l'actuel président serge
belley et l'ancien jacqueline faucher
tous deux seront entendus par la justice
la semaine prochaine dans le cadre d'une
information judiciaire pour abus de
biens sociaux et escroqueries sont
étonnés que vous soyez encore là alors
que vous êtes mise en examen alors il a
par exemple sur l'innocence ce cher
monsieur qu'est ce que vous en faites
vous savez des erreurs tout le monde a
commis bon journée sur mon corps me veut
plus comme prêtre feront gagner en
excellents par paquets de douze
aujourd'hui la spa est une énorme
machine 52 refus 500 salariés
deux mille deux cents bénévoles ah si la
protection désintéresser des animaux
reste le principe certains humains se
sont soignés au passage il y avait des
potentats locaux des petits barons
locaux qui à tel ou tel endroit avec qui
des caisses noires qui
des avantages une voiture de fonction le
paiement de remboursement de frais comme
ça forfaitaire au moins ce qui est
interdit par la loi des désavantages de
cette nature ces petits arrangements ont
fait naître de gros soupçons que
l'actuel président tente d'écarter nous
ne rentrerons pas dans ces luttes de
clans ou dans ses luttes d'équipements
chez lui de pouvoir
une crise qui tombe bien mal au moment
où la spa lance sa traditionnelle
campagne estivale contre l'abandon des
animaux nous massacres en algérie cette
fois ci c'est un autobus qui a été pris
pour cible près de l'aéroport à quelques
kilomètres de la capitale 13 voyageurs
ont été assassinés neuf autres ont été
blessés par balles terrible série depuis
le début du mois de juin plus de 100
personnes ont été tuées
anne consigny la furie n'a pas eu lieu
dans une contrée reculée mais sur cette
route en banlieue d'alger au lieu dit
les eucalyptus
hier soir les assaillants étaient entre
5 et 8 selon les témoins ils ont
mitraillé le minibus en commençant par
le chauffeur une fusillade qui a semblé
durer une éternité aux survivants treize
personnes ont trouvé la mort dans le
minibus neuf autres sont blessées c'est
la troisième fois en quinze jours que
les terroristes s'attaquent ainsi à des
bus et les exploitants de transport en
commun de la région
le nas d'interrompre leurs services si
le gouvernement n'assure pas leur
sécurité
selon cet homme qui a évacué les blessés
le chauffeur s'est arrêté à l'arrêt de
bus croyant que les assaillants étaient
des passagers
il a eu le temps d'ouvrir les portes et
les terroristes ont commencé à tirer
les eucalyptus viennent donc de renouer
avec la violence cette zone jadis située
dans un bastion de la guérilla islamiste
échappé depuis quatre ans aux yeux sur
l'ensemble de l'algérie ces attentats
que le pouvoir attribué à des rebelles
islamistes ont tué plus de 600 civils
depuis le début de l'année c'est à dire
depuis six mois l'armée israélienne
attaque à hébron un nouveau symbole de
l'autorité palestinienne après un siège
de plusieurs jours le bâtiment a été
détruit la nuit dernière des activistes
qui aurait trouvé refuge dans le qg ont
été tués mais aucun corps pour l'instant
n'a été découvert et derrière cette
opération c'est yasser arafat qui est un
peu plus affaiblie
charles enderlin sa mère jeanne les
israéliens la siégeait depuis cinq jours
une vingtaine de palestiniens qui s'y
trouvaient s'était déjà constitué
prisonnier
mais les militaires affirmaient qu'il
restait à l'intérieur du bâtiment
une quinzaine de combattants du fatah
la nuit dernière considérant qu'il
refusait de se rendre
l'armée a mis en place deux tonnes
d'explosifs
et ce matin du symbole de l'autorité
d'arafat à hébron il ne restait plus
qu'un amas de béton et de ferraille
ces personnes refusaient de se rendre ce
sont des terroristes avec du sang sur
les mains
mais sachez qu'à l'heure actuelle nous
n'avons trouvé aucun corps sous les
décombres
à hébron ce responsable palestinien a
été autorisé par l'armée israélienne à
inspecter l'immeuble
hier pendant deux heures et il affirme
qu'il était vise djibril radjoub le chef
de la sécurité palestinienne accuse donc
les israéliens dès le début dit il nous
pensions que leur objectif était
uniquement la destruction du bâtiment
il n'empêche les militaires israéliens
affirment avoir capturé une cinquantaine
du terroriste et détruit un laboratoire
d'explosifs
toutes les grandes villes de cisjordanie
sont toujours occupée par l'armée
israélienne
à partir de demain le couvre feu il sera
levé durant la journée et la question
sera donc de savoir qui va gérer la vie
quotidienne de 850 mille civils
palestiniens
en france quelques informations
économiques s'il vous reste des bons
vieux francs en poche vous avez encore
quelques heures pour l'échanger à votre
banque
en fait jusqu'au 30 juin minuit après il
faudra se rendre à la banque de france
pour toute transaction
et puis le gouvernement pourrait
accorder un délai d'un mois pour le
paiement du troisième tiers de l'impôt
sur le revenu au lieu du 15 septembre la
date retenue serait celle du 15 octobre
il s'agira de raisons techniques que
résultant de la baisse de l'impôt prévu
mais pour l'instant pas de confirmation
officielle depuis le deuxième tour des
législatives que de turbulences au parti
socialiste qui tient aujourd'hui son
conseil national après des journées de
crise ouverte
laurent fabius qui est notre invité fait
son entrée comme numéro deux au ps et
non comme porte parole ce qui avait
provoqué un véritable tollé notamment
auprès de martine aubry qui avait mis sa
démission dans la balance désormais le
parti socialiste a une direction
remaniée élargi on pourra parler d'unité
dans la diversité alexandre kara
claudine cren un grand sourire de
soulagement
françois hollande a réussi son premier
examen de passage de l'après j'ose pas
l'unité du ps est préservé après dix
jours de psychodrame autour du kata bus
l'entrée à la direction du parti du
grand méchant loup social libéral n'a
pas provoqué le clash annoncé sommes ni
un troupeau sans berger ni
des petits agneaux attendant je ne sais
qu'elle loue pour les forêts pourtant le
patron des socialistes a bien été
ballotté par l'affrontement entre trèbes
luziens et gauche du ps résultat une
coalition de circonstance contre loupé a
annoncé sur le parti de l'ancien
ministre de l'économie
neutralisé laurent fabius pour
neutraliser laurent fabius ça s'appelle
la chasse à l'homme et c c'est parce que
c'est pas acceptable
il s'agissait d'empêcher que ce qui
représente une certaine sensibilité
parce main basse sur le parti socialiste
à ce moment du débat une offensive
accompagné par martine aubry avec une
menace de démission de la direction du
ps dans la balance
et là aussi il paraît que ce n'est pas
une affaire d'hommes mais bien une
question principe et pas contre laurent
fabius particulièrement jeu
sur mêlant chant hemani strauss kahn ou
moi même ayant été proposé comme porte
parole je crois que la réaction aurait
été exactement la même au final le
conseil national a donc accouché d'une
direction a semblé en quelque sorte
l'unité après la défaite les questions
qui fâchent attendront le congrès du ps
au printemps 2003 le temps pour chacun
de préparer sa stratégie et surtout de
compter ses partisans enfin lui ce bon
soir soit que de remous et d'opposition
à votre égard
ces derniers jours alors peut-être un
mot de réaction un sentiment d'injustice
meurtri blessé soudage et peut-être ce
soir envie de claquer la porte à un
moment non pas du tout pas du tout j'ai
pas la même interprétation que ce qu'on
vient de voir mais je vais vous dire les
choses sur le plan personnel dans un
instant mes parents ils pouvoir quelle
est la question de fond bon on a pris
une défaite terrible aux élections est
d'abord lorsque je souhaite aller 3è et
le pen deuxième bon c'est là-bas deux
précédents donc et après la défaite aux
législatives donc la défaite est
extrêmement sévère et je pense que
partir de là il faut il faut réfléchir
mais c'était leur déchirement justement
justement parce que j'ai pas lors du
rassemblement justement pas il fallait
réfléchir
il fallait commencer à rebâtir et
essayer de réunir dans ce cadre là à
détruire [ __ ] toile à détruire ce
cadre la sauce candidature si je puis
dire de porter dans ce cadre la fosse
hollande proposé d'être le porte parole
des socialistes
et il y a eu quelques oppositions les
unes des personnes qui sont minoritaires
au parti chez se peut donc je comprendre
les autres dont entre autres personnes
bon très bien moi je suis resté
silencieux je pense que c'était la nuit
à faire et aujourd'hui
bon les choses sont
mon avis sur le bon qu'à d'amour je suis
le numéro deux du parti social il en
vise est resté entier je suis numéro
deux du parti socialiste va pouvoir bien
travailler tous ensemble une question de
personnes c'est je ne pense pas que ça
empêche les français de dormir les
français doivent se dire qu'est ce que
c'est que ces histoires des socialistes
qui devrait se réunir qui se battrait
tous ceux fabius et le copier vilain
petit canard de ses reins pas de sens or
on a tout subi une défaite massive
maintenant il faut reconstruire faut
réfléchir et moi je veux apporter ma
pierre comme l'a justement numéro deux
du parti socialiste
est ce que c'est un type ou est ce que
c'est un rôle les deux mon général
est-ce que vous avez bien sûr je
n'aurais pas une fonction une
attribution spécialisés mais tu vas une
fonction transversale pour préparer avec
françois hollande mettre en application
les réflexions et les décisions du ps
et ça va permettre à beaucoup d'autres
et y'a pas que noailles de strauss kahn
yad'autres qui entre à la direction
ça va faire de rassembler tout le monde
parce que on à rebâtir tout ça et c'est
une tâche qui fait parler de
rassemblement
vos idées sont les vôtres certains
parlent de social libéral on sait grâce
à je n'aimais pas le taire non mais
c'est pas bien pourquoi c'est que je
crois qu'il n'est pas juste du tout moi
je suis socialiste je n'ai jamais été
que socialiste depuis plus de 20 ans et
honnêtement je pense comme comme
beaucoup beaucoup de gens que les
valeurs du socialisme sont les mêmes
depuis très très longtemps mais qu' il
faut proposer un projet qui soit en
ligne avec la société moderne et sûre ça
dont on a parlé aujourd'hui projet n'est
pas partagé par tous soit un dollar par
tous les pores bourdonné dans le
reportage est commun faire ma base sur
le pardon de vous allez bien vous êtes
minoritaires dans ces notes est proche
de l'europe à l'aide d'une hernie t non
non seulement je vais pas m'y arrêter
on a parlé de quoi j'ai cause de la
défaite la division le fait qu'on n'a
pas assez insisté sur l'autorité de
l'état le fait qu'on n'a pas assez
insisté sur la valeur du travail qu'est
ce que le fait d'européens que vous
reprochez chansons d'amour sur rien mais
toutes les manières il faut être calme
cool et vous dès maintenant pour 4 alors
5 pour deux questions essentielles avant
signèrent d'abord on ne vous a pas
entendu sur l'audit du gouvernement donc
si on regarde les suivre en france voilà
yar d'euros au lieu des 300 non c'est
pas apparemment pas apparemment les sept
prévues avec 2,6 mais un vrai sens des
chiffres jouer bon il ya deux choses
différentes
il y a l'aude et et pia son exploitation
l'audit vicoire qu'en 2000 pour les
recettes elles sont en ligne même s'il
ya eu un certain tassement de la
croissance bien pour les dépenses
budgétaires le budget de l'état il y a
un certain dérapage
à mon avis moins important que ce qu'il
dit dans l'audit et qui est classique
n'aviez pas annoncé aussi parce que ce
qu'on oublie de dire c'est que vous ne
savez peut-être bas c'est que toutes les
semaines les hautes autorités de l'état
et les présidents des commissions des
finances reçoivent ce qu'on appelle la
situation budgétaire de la france deux
cas aucune surprise ni pour le président
de la république mais pour l'ancien
président la commission du sénat qui est
devenu ministre du budget tous ces parcs
été entonné le français et puis il ya un
problème moi je lui ai toujours dit vous
le rappeler sur les dépenses sociales
parce que des pans de santé augmentent
énormément vite et ça ça pose un
problème
ça c'est la réalité de l'audit qui est
traditionnel à partir de laâyoune
exploitation politicienne
parce qu'il ya une habitude quand une
nouvelle équipe rives de charger ses
prédécesseurs c'est ce qui est fait
cette fois ci
et en plus comme la nouvelle équipe a
promis beaucoup de choses
eh bien ça rentre pas dans le cas donc
l'audit c'est une manière de préparer
les retranchements mais moi je vais
faire une proposition parce que c'est
pas normal si vous voulez on a vu le
même problème en sens inverse à la
précédente alternant être opposition à
la proposition c'est que la cour des
comptes qui me paraît le mieux placé
pour le faire désormais rendre public
son audit mais pas après six mois avant
les élections et donc là il sera plus
possible comme on l'a vu dans cette
campagne de faire la démagogie parce que
les comptes seront publiés
six mois avant les élections c'est la
proposition que je fais et ça les vrais
absolument tout politique
merci monsieur n'à us et nous verrons
dans cinq ans la disparition de françois
périer une vie entière consacrée à la
comédie pendant plus d'un demi-siècle il
passe avec le même bonheur de la caméra
à la scène de jean paul sartre à godard
françois périer qui c'était un âge de 82
laissant derrière lui plus une centaine
de films et presque autant de pièces de
théâtre georges beccu gens regrette le
président mais je ne vois pas pourquoi
j'emploierai des formules de politesse
avec un individu qui est c'est
systématiquement de me faire dire le
contraire de ce que j'avance et qui ne
va pas par quatre chemins la fin de ce
procès pour demander à messieurs les
jurés de me faire couper la tête
je répète on parfait de conscience les
termes de ma déclaration jeudi que
monsieur l'avocat général ouvre la
bouche pour dire des conneries
françois périer triompha dans vos bosse
plus de 2000 fois depuis son premier
succès dans les jours heureux en 1938 il
n'a cessé d'enchanter le théâtre et 200
chanter lui même d'être comédien je suis
assez content d'être comédien à ce que
pensent bon à l'époque où nous vivons la
déraison qui très souvent et la règle de
vie de nos contemporains comme je suis
assez content de ne pas vraiment
appartenir à ce monde là des raisons il
a joué jusqu'à la folie dans gervaise
françois périer partage avec autant de
bonheur sa carrière de menteurs
professionnels comme il se plaisait à le
dire entre cinéma et théâtre le théâtre
c'est là où c'est un admirable c'est de
donner la parole à ses adversaires
comment il faut le faire l'équipe et un
tu poses que cette main qui est une arme
et que ce douala soit posée sur la ja
c'est le schéma suppose que je sois
devant toi exactement comme je suis et
que mes et chez moi travaillons du moyen
et au moment d'appuyer sur la gâchette
voilà que tu penses si c'était lui qui
avait raison
tu pourrais pas de frein empêcher ça
vaudrait mieux parce que city pensait
pas avant très pas trop tout t il pour y
penser après qu'il fut l'interprète
magistrale des pièces de sartre qui
vendent
comme un menu pour installer [ __ ] dans
un château historique pour faire coucher
une [ __ ] dans le lit de ma mère
regarde toi tu m'aimes pas de bata 3
contres avant j'ai dit aux gars
françois périer le diabolique pouvait
être aussi étonnant dans le drame que
dans cadet rousselle une comédie le cap
et d'essai
quelques années plus tard il retrouve
bourvil dans le cercle rouge où il campe
un super beau mafieux
veston bd à lui pourquoi venez-vous chez
moi commissaire pour tout le monde le
voit et finissent par penser que jean
crocs et drôlement galvanisé jeux de
suite les grands mots
il est aussi convaincant dans les grands
truands que dans les grands flics je
suis chargé de la tête pour nanterre un
point c'est tout je sais ce que j'ai à
faire et je vous signale que vous n'avez
pas ou mal et mon district vous avez
décidé cette affaire je suis pas permis
de vous dire c'est en français
foutez lui la paix c'est ce qu'ils les
autres petits cons on va les laisser en
paix sans cette fille très libre comme
il l'avait fait autrefois dans orphée
françois perrier a aujourd'hui traversé
le miroir emportant avec lui son secret
du bonheur moi le bonheur et fugitif
pour le saisir
mais il faut pas tout lui sacrifier à ce
qu'on risque d'être déçu équilibre c'est
important garder la tête froide mais
savoir c'est un peu dias mais chacun
s'accorde à reconnaître que françois
péry a été l'un des comédiens les plus
populaires de sa génération
écoutons tout de suite l'émotion et les
réactions de ses proches ou de ceux qui
ont été ses partenaires olivier lénine à
christophe airaud 1988 l'intelligence
l'humanité de françois périer récompensé
par un molière d'honneur le roi une rue
en son royaume
toute notre affection françois 1er et
avec toute notre admiration aussi merci
c'est red bull
c'était vraiment un comédien d'instinct
dans les villes et grandes et vraies
et me disait toujours savez georges
roncé ce jour dire oui vous voyez c'est
avant le métier se trouve ça très beau
parce que il avait le sens de la du
respect des autres corps unique en perte
pour ça parce qu'on ne fait plus ces
artistes là
il avait un esprit très caustique
et là devrait faire des bonbons
même les bons mots cateau et jamais
méchant mais si elle sait qu'ils
pouvaient mettre les gens en difficulté
il fait le charme eux-mêmes et et la
drôlerie même en même temps c'était un
garçon exquis jouer à la marelle sur ce
trottoir
et il ya des prénoms qui me reviennent
en mémoire vraiment
suzanne
roger a bien qui il fit de sa vie un jeu
jeu d'acteur de comédien fidèle à sa
terre d'enfance françois périer vivait
dans un autre monde fait d'élégance et
de modestie
l'accueil est exportée avec d'abord la
victoire de la turquie qui s'empare de
la troisième place du mondial contre la
corée du sud du jeu et les en avait
christophe guichard 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 et
10 10 secondes dans la vie d'un homme
qu'est ce que ça représente finalement
pas grand chose mais dans la carrière du
turc hakan sukkur ça compte parce que
c'est historique en 10 secondes
il est devenu le buteur le plus rapide
de la coupe du monde bien aidé par la
défense coréenne qui avait décrété une
journée portes ouvertes à ce moment-là
séoul à l'école des fans des diables
rouges au dîner il n'ya soupe à la
grimace neuf minutes de jeu sur coup
franc lire lyon égalise pour la corée du
sud d'un tir splendide et précis pile en
lucarne
à séoul c'est maintenant l'école du rire
explosion de joie et festival
pyrotechnique mais sur le terrain ce
sont les turcs qui continuent leur
festival offensif en contre attaque un
tour de passe passe à cannes s'ouvre aux
mails allemands disent qui envoie le
ballon dans les filets 13 minutes de jeu
2 1 pour la turquie
32e minute du match et un et deux et
troisième buts pour les cures on prend
les mêmes et on recommence à cannes sous
forêts la demande six petits chinois et
jolie pichenette 3 1 pour la turquie
les coréens réduiront le score pendant
les arrêts de jeu son tir et marque est
plongé dans une sorte de prière
il doit remercier dieu du ballon rond et
la fesse droite de son copain cha doo-ri
qui détourne la balle dans les filets
score final 3 à 2
monture que la victoire aux coréens la
médaille en chocolat et les jeunes
filles en pleurs
et pourtant il y avait matière à se
féliciter au terme d'un vrai match de
football avec deux équipes qui
cherchaient d'abord à marquer avant de
défendre sur que ces coréens offrait
l'image de fair play la plus forte qui
soit bras dessus bras dessous
vainqueurs et vaincus acteurs
magnifiques d'une petite finale qui
valait tellement mieux beaucoup de
finale pendant ce temps là en turquie
sur le bosphore navigue est un bateau
troisième de la coupe du monde pour les
turcs et les majorettes c'était le
pompon
c'est donc de mal la finale de la coupe
du monde l'allemagne s'y prépare avec
ferveur campagne électorale ou pas le
premier supporter n'est autre que
gerhard schröder portait déjà par la
victoire de son équipe en demi-finale
correspondance patrice rundle le
chancelier schröder a vu tous les
matches et il l'a fait savoir
limité comme il se doit par le fin
gourmet et demie steuble les deux hommes
se disputent actuellement la
chancellerie le pratiquent donc le
marquage à la culotte bavaroise bien sûr
il est vrai qu'ils ont tout à gagner
dans cette affaire car il se murmure
puis une victoire stimuler le moral donc
la consommation des allemands à la
vérité les choses sont enclenchées il
n'est qu'à voir l'ardeur avec laquelle
les cafetiers peaufinent leur
préparation
on a déjà quatre télévisions dans le bar
on va en rajouter deux en terrasse et
bien sûr on a commandé des hectolitres
de bière le t-shirt spécial finale vient
de sortir 9 euros 90 autrement dit pas
grand chose en tout cas pour les
retardataires qui se sont arrachés les
derniers billets jusqu'à 800 euros et
n'hésite pas à en débourser 2000 de plus
pour s'offrir le week end au japon
l'objectif assister au triomphe oliver
kahn ait donné raison à cette publicité
que les brésiliens ferait mieux de se
passer en boucle car comment dire c'est
une allégorie du style de jeu des
allemands à savoir pas toujours élégant
mais souvent efficace pour quant au
brésil où le football est roi les
églises du pays vont retarder la messe
du dimanche pour que chacun puisse
assister à la retransmission du match
dans le culte du ballon orange un moment
des dida c'est le seul brésilien resté
de marbre
à quelques heures de la finale le christ
contemple rio de janeiro et ses
nouvelles couleurs
une ville en jaune et vert comme
l'équipe brésilienne
un concours a même été organisé il
récompense la rue la plus décorée pour
les retardataires qui n'ont pas encore
la tenue du supporters direction le
quartier sahara un quartier loin d'être
désert mais plutôt que de se casser la
voix il existe d'autres méthodes pour
soutenir les jeunes en magasin on a
aussi ça il faut le mettre autour du cou
on appuie là et on souffle comme ça on
est derrière l'équipe du brésil pour
voir ronaldo sur le terrain il faudra se
lever demain à huit derniers tours au
marché pour les produits frais les
brésiliens ont prévu de se retrouver en
famille à chacun son monde
j'ai acheté du chou pour préparer une
choucroute
c'est bien demain on va manger
l'allemagne tout entière au petit
déjeuner ces prix des fruits pour
freiner ambiance tropicale elle est
brésilienne à copacabana on s'active
également pour la première fois depuis
le début de la coupe du monde
un écran géant va être installée ici
surface 18 mètres carrés face à la mer
deux écoles de samba ont été invités une
partie de la rue va même être fermée aux
voitures trio a tout fait pour que la
fête soit réussie
la balle est maintenant dans le camp de
l'équipe brésilienne comme vous l'avez
vu ce midi en direct sur france 2 la
victoire
vie de l'austrasie contre la france sur
un score de 31 25
le stade olympique de sydney malgré un
bel essai d'aurélien rougerie
en fin de rencontre les français
s'incline pour la deuxième fois en une
semaine face à l'australie une page
vacances à présent ce week-end commence
dans toute la france l'opération
tranquillité vacances une formule qui
sécurise les habitants contre les
cambriolages d'exemple à paris charlotte
millet alexis fischer contrôler les 10,6
assurer une présence dans les lieux
désertés pendant l'été voici le
programme de ces policiers de quartier
pour l'opération tranquillité vacances
là tout simplement une année les voleurs
sont entrés par cette fenêtre
donc on vérifie que les lieux ce bien
fermé donc là maintenant nous allons
faire le tour de la maison pour voir si
les volets sont bien ferme et ils n'ont
pas été abîmées
chacun de ces policiers va effectuer
deux patrouilles par jour à chaque fois
cinq à dix maisons à visiter un
gardiennage personnalisé ouvert à tous
gratuitement
seule condition s'inscrire au moins deux
jours avant de partir personne
commissariat où quelqu'un lui demande de
s'inscrire sur une fiche quand l on
demande des renseignements nécessaires
notamment son identité
l'adresse bien entendu on peut aussi
s'inscrire par simple courrier adressé
au commissariat c'est ce qu'a fait ce
médecin une habituée de l'opération
depuis le cambriolage de son cabinet il
y a cinq ans plus tranquille tout à fait
surtout que à mon retour généralement il
laisse un petit mot et ça marche
l'été dernier sur les 240 maisons et
appartements surveiller aucun n'a été
cambriolé dans l'arrondissement des
stations balnéaires se prépare à
l'arrivée des vacanciers des campeurs ou
des amateurs de bateaux comme à la
grande meute ou le port de plaisance
affiche complet carole clos française
mais d'où la grande motte s'apprête à
recevoir 1400 bateaux de plaisance cet
homme un rôle fondamental dans la
préparation du port
comptez les places encore disponibles
vérifier les équipements on revoit
toutes les structures portuaires que ça
soit de la signalétique bien évidemment
on double les équipes de sécurité ont
doublé les équipes d'accueil de jour
depuis des mois la ville prépare la
nouvelle saison c'est la moitié du
budget de la commune en été la
population est multipliée parti s'il
faut tout prévoir
les services de voiries les services
d'un de l'environnement général à
l'alimentation en passant par
l'alimentation à nous l'entretien des
espaces verts dans ce camping il ya
encore du travail
ce mobile homme doit être prêt ce soir
on attend plusieurs dizaines de familles
les touristes étrangers c'est 50% de la
clientèle du camping pour leur accueil
le propriétaire a spécialement recruté
ses employés on a tenu et surtout
engager du personnel de trilingue à
l'accueil
puisqu'on a une forte clientèle
européenne particulièrement les
allemands des hollandais des danois des
finlandais
côté sécurité les effectifs de la police
municipale ont été doublés ils vont
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
les postes de secours sur les plages
ici les sauveteurs sont frais depuis
plusieurs jours les premiers vacanciers
sont arrivés ils peuvent aller se
baigner
c'est aujourd'hui que débute à paris les
défilés de la mode masculine pour l'été
2003 avec notamment la collection de
jean paul gaultier sur les podiums
l'extravagance des créateurs dans la rue
des tenues bien plus sage de l'essentiel
à l'accessoire voici quelques
propositions de code vestimentaire
estelle cola rigaud rivas heures même si
la plupart des hommes commencent à
apprécier la mode
le chemin est souvent semée d'embûches
pression sociale peur de se distinguer
ils ne sont pas prêts à se lâcher en
technicolor effrayé par l'idée de perdre
un peu de leur virilité
pourtant certains créateurs y travaille
depuis des années je les ai juste penser
petit à petit à se sentir à l'aise cette
idée avant beaucoup étaient nerveux à ce
sujet
si je porte de la couleur ce sera celui
d'un dandy réflexion comme ça
des propositions extravagantes des
créateurs comme cet après midi chez jean
paul gaultier connu mondialement pour
son sens de la mise en scène à la mode
de la rue il y as parfois ne vous
pourtant tout cela n'est pas anodin
c'est grande attention dans les défilés
permet de décomplexer l'homme à
plusieurs niveaux et de lui donner le
droit à nouveau à la séduction à la
réappropriation de son corps à l'euro
matière de loin de là aussi on se
comporte pas en société comme dans sa
vie privée l'habit fait le moine
ils donnent à leurs compétences les
contraintes c'est l'adaptation à
l'univers dans lequel vous évoluez en
sachant que ces contraintes seront
d'autant plus forte que vous avez des
responsabilités qui vous conduisent à
être en relation avec un client le
client doit être respectée doit tête et
donc vous devez un peu vous effacer
devant lui les tons sombres reste un
gage de sérieux la chemise blanche
symbole de respectabilité et la cravate
d'obéissance social échappée est
quelques règles n'est pas souvent tâche
facile
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous
remercie de votre attention tout de
suite la météo avec nathalie rihouet
20h50 fort boyard présenté par cendrine
dominguez et jean pierre castaldi ces
horreurs 45 le dernier journal présenté
par eve mettait quant à moi j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver demain dès 13h
et on se quitte avec ses images de grand
voilier au large du port allemand de
kiel une importante régate qui rassemble
chaque année plus de cinq milles marins
de différents pays